I'm here to talk about climate change
but I'm not really an environmentalist
in fact I've never really thought of
myself as a nature person I have never
gone camping never gone hiking never
even owned a pet I've lived my whole
life in cities actually just one city
and while I like to take trips to visit
nature I always thought it was something
that was happening elsewhere far away
with all of modern life a fortress
against its forces in other words like
just about everybody I knew I lived my
life complacent and deluded about the
threat from global warming which I took
to be happening slowly happening at a
distance and representing only a modest
threat to the way that I lived in each
of these ways I was very very wrong now
most people if they were telling you
about climate change will tell you a
story about the future if I was doing
that I would say according to the UN if
we don't change course by the end of the
century we're likely to get about 4
degrees Celsius of warming that would
mean some scientists believe twice as
much war half as much food a global GDP
possibly 20% smaller than it would be
without climate change that's an impact
that's deeper than the Great Depression
and it would be permanent but the
impacts are actually happening a lot
faster than 2100 by just 2050 it's
estimated many of the biggest cities in
South Asia and the Middle East will be
almost literally unlivable hot in summer
these are cities that today are home to
10 12 15 million people and in just
three decades you wouldn't be able to
walk around outside in them without
risking heatstroke or possibly death
the planet is now 1.1 degrees Celsius
warmer than it was before
industrialization that may not sound
like a lot but it actually puts us
entirely outside the window of
temperatures that enclose all of human
history that means that everything we
have ever known as a species the
evolution of the human animal the
development of Agriculture the
development of rudimentary civilization
and modern civilization and industrial
civilization everything we know about
ourselves as biological creatures as
social creatures as political creatures
all of it is the result of climate
conditions we have already left behind
it's like we've landed on an entirely
different planet
with an entirely different climate and
we now have to figure out what of the
civilization that we've brought with us
can endure these new conditions and what
can't and things will get worse from
here now for a very long time we were
told that climate change was a slow saga
it started with the Industrial
Revolution and it had fallen to us to
clean up the mess left by our
grandparents so our grandchildren
wouldn't be dealing with the results it
was a story of centuries in fact half of
all of the emissions that have ever been
produced from the burning of fossil
fuels in the entire history of humanity
have been produced in just the last 30
years that since Al Gore published his
first book on warming its since the UN
established its IPCC climate change body
we've done more damage since then than
in all the centuries all the millennia
before now I'm 37 years old which means
my life contains this entire story when
I was born the planet's climate seemed
stable today we are on the brink of
catastrophe
crisis is not the legacy of our
ancestors this is the work of a single
generation ours
this may all sound like bad news which
it is really bad news but it also
contains I think some good news at least
relatively speaking these impacts are
terrifyingly large but they are also I
think exhilarating because they are
ultimately a reflection of how much
power we have over the climate if we get
to those hellish scenarios it will be
because we have made them happen because
we have chosen to make them happen which
means we can choose to make other
scenarios happen too now that may seem
too rosy to believe and the political
obstacles are in fact enormous but it is
a simple fact the main driver of global
warming is human action how much carbon
we put into the atmosphere our hands are
on those levers and we can write the
story of the planet's climate future
ourselves not just Ken but our since
inaction is a kind of action we'll be
writing that story ourselves whether we
like it or not this is not just any
story all of us holding the future of
the planet in our hands it's the kind of
story we used to recognize only in
mythology and theology a single
generation that has brought the future
of humanity into doubt now tasked with
securing a new future so what would that
look like it could mean solar arrays
Barna clean the planet really everywhere
you looked
it could mean if we developed battery
technology wouldn't we wouldn't even
need to deploy them that broadly because
it's been estimated that just a sliver
of the Sahara Desert absorbs enough
solar power to provide all the world's
energy needs but we probably need a new
electric grid one that doesn't lose 2/3
of its power to waste heat as is today
the case in the u.s.
we couldn't use some more nuclear power
perhaps although it would have to be an
entirely different kind of nuclear power
because today's technology simply isn't
cost competitive with renewable energy
whose costs are falling so rapidly we
need a new kind of plane because I don't
think it's particularly practical to ask
the entire world to give up on air
travel especially as so much of the
global South is for the very first time
able to afford it
we need planes that won't produce carbon
we need a new kind of Agriculture
because we probably can't ask people to
entirely give up on meat and go vegan it
would mean a new way of raising beef or
perhaps an old way since we already know
the traditional pasturing practices can
turn cattle farms from what are called
carbon sources which produce co2 into
carbon sinks which absorb them if you
prefer a techno solution maybe we can
grow some of that meat in a lab probably
we could also feed some real cattle
seaweed because that cuts their methane
emissions by as much as 95 or 99 percent
probably we'd have to do all of these
things because as with every aspect of
this puzzle the problem is simply too
vast and complicated to solve in any
single silver bullet way and no matter
how many solutions we deploy we probably
won't be able to decarbonize in time
that's the terrifying math that we face
we won't be able to beat climate change
only live with it and limit it and that
means we'd probably need some amount of
what are called negative emissions which
take carbon out of the atmosphere as
well billions of new trees maybe
trillions of new trees and whole
plantations of carbon capture machines
perhaps an industry twice or four times
the size of today's oil and gas business
to undo the damage that was done by
those businesses in past decades we
would need a new kind of infrastructure
poured by a different kind of cement
because today if cement were a country
it would be the world's third biggest
emitter and China's pouring as much
cement every three years as the US
poured in the entire 20th century we
would need to build sea walls and levees
to protect those
people living on the coast many of whom
are too poor to build them today which
is why it must mean an end to a narrowly
nationalistic geopolitics that allows us
to define the suffering of those living
elsewhere in the world as insignificant
when we even acknowledge it this better
future won't be easy but the only
obstacles are human ones
that may not be much of a comfort if you
know what I know about human brutality
and indifference but I promise you it is
better than the alternative science
isn't stopping us from taking action and
neither is technology we have the tools
we need today to begin of course we also
have the tools we needed to end global
poverty epidemic disease and the abuse
of women as well which is why more than
new tools we need a new politics a way
of overcoming all those human obstacles
our culture our economics our status quo
bias our disinterest in taking seriously
anything that really scares us our
shortsightedness our sense of
self-interest and the selfishness of the
world's rich and powerful who have the
least incentive to change anything now
they will suffer too but not as much as
those with the least who have done the
least to produce warming and have
benefited the least from the processes
that have brought us to this crisis
point but will be burdened most in the
decades ahead a new politics would make
the matter of managing that burden where
it falls and how heavily the top
priority of our time no matter what we
do
climate change will transform modern
life some amount of warming is already
baked in and is inevitable which means
probably some amount of additional
suffering is too and even if we take
dramatic action and avoid some of these
truly terrifying worst-case scenarios it
would mean living on an entirely
different planet with a new politics a
new economics a new relationship to
technology and the new relationship to
nature a whole new world but a
relatively livable one relatively
prosperous and green why not choose that
one thank you
[Applause]